- Let's get magical.
- I'm a huge fan of Harry Potter.
I've often wondered what did the stuff
that they drink in
Harry Potter taste like?
- Seriously, this is just like
my whole life has been
leading to this moment.
- Accio butterbeer!
- [Both] Oh!
- It worked, it worked!
- Oh, wow.
- Oh, that's good.
- That's real good.
- This would go great
on a cold winter day.
- This tastes more like liquor than beer.
- Yeah, I had the butterbeer
at Harry Potter World.
They have it chilled,
it's icy there, but...
I think it's better when it's
warm and it's with alcohol.
- Who wouldn't want to have a first date
over a toasty glass of butterbeer?
- So, basically, this is preventing us
from turning into the
werewolves that we're not.
- That you're not.
- I don't know if any of the
potions actually taste good.
- They should put some
sugar in that (bleep).
- This does look like medicine.
This looks like cough syrup.
- It does.
- Oh, that's pretty good.
- Oh! (laughs)
- That's good enough for me.
- Looks like I'm about
to start a juice cleanse
with a wheatgrass shot.
- In the books, Polyjuice
Potion tastes nasty.
- Yeah, it's disgusting.
- And it's supposed to
turn us into somebody else,
if we have a little bit
of their DNA inside.
- Uh, I would wanna turn
into Beyonce, hands down.
- I guess whoever's married to Paul Rudd?
- Tastes like an alcoholic salad.
- It's not really love,
it's more like an obsession.
You just become infatuated.
- Yeah.
- That's delightful.
- [Man] That is like--
- [Woman] That's refreshing.
- I would serve that
cocktail at my wedding.
- Oh, that's so good!
- I'm obsessed with this!
- It just tastes like Kool-Aid.
- It's pretty good.
I love Kool-Aid.
- Look at that.
- It tastes like love.
- It tastes so good.
- Would I drink many of these?
No, it only takes one to
find your one true love.
- I only wanna drink unicorn blood.
That sounds (bleep)ing amazing.
- Maybe you're in Slytherin. (laughs)
- This is great.
- Ooh, it's punchy.
- Oh, that's pretty good.
- Nuh-uh.
- It's tart, it's like lemonade.
- Ooh, yeah, that's
some nice unicorn blood.
- That's some high quality (bleep).
- Sorry, unicorns, I'm
gonna drink your blood.
- [Woman] Yikes, ugh.
- [Man] All day every day.
- This is the best!
Liquid Luck!
God, when you read that
passage, you were like,
I want to go through a day like this.
- This is what I think
cactus would taste like.
- Oh, that's nice.
- Okay, we're lucky?
- We're lucky.
We're in love.
- We're immortal.
- We're...
we look like one another.
- We look like each other, apparently.
- We're gonna go to Vegas.
- Ready?
- We need more smoke.
(woman laughs)
Accio smoke!
(gasps)
- You're magic!
All right, you have to, I'm gonna fly.
Get out of my way, I'm gonna fly.